kenji est ce que tu peux nous faire
israël c'est la première fois que tu me
ferait alors ce n'était pas prévu du
tout mais j'aimerais beaucoup que tu
nous fasses quand même là les yeux damas
bas à la ja merkel a et moi je ferai des
yeux de la papa veut nous faire tu veux
rester atone et comme tu veux comme tu
veux bien mais mes toiles assez bien là
sans que je puisse plus le faire comme
ça merci vas-y moi j'ai froid à se faire
lumière comme un soleil dans l'existence
quand j'ai mal se fait prier et me dit
tout dans un silence jeu sauf rennes
souffre avec moi quand je ris elle rit
aux éclats
mes chansons sont souvent pour elle il
sera toujours ma merveille quand je ne
suis pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
le meilleur c'est l'ensemble qui est
content mais vaine et le souvenir d'une
centaine percement coeur dany l'étoile
cinéma
[Musique]
au monde
c'est moi mais bon jeu
[Musique]
elle va porter un
le banc
l important dans ses dents tellement
porteur
je vais lui un soir est toujours vide
[Applaudissements]
et son papa est franchement je l' ai
rêvé ce moment dans cette émission je
suis très heureux vraiment que que ça se
passe est-ce qu'on avait quelque chose à
dire à kenji ce que c'est réglé vous l'a
dit en chansons est-ce que ce soit vous
avez quelque chose à lui dire
moi c'est mon bonheur au mignon c'est
toute ma vie
vous suivez tout ce qui fait à huy ce
soir vous saviez qu'il avait une
spéciale depuis longtemps si vous suivez
toute cette élite tout ce qu'il fait et
le pape a aussi oui mais si il est petit
mais c'est vrai que c'est votre fierté
d'un homme
franchement merci d'avoir été là il est
également